or it's basically a two-hour special
that goes from a beach on earth right
out to the beginning of time to be back
but it does it in one single category
that means no cards no dissolves nothing
when you make an animated film it's a
completely different process from normal
factual documentary where you go out and
film sequences and bring them back and
you edit them and you have control over
how you edit a program with an animation
film you have to basically edit the film
before you film it for instance if we
were to be able to go and film Mars in
reality we would go out there we film as
much as we wanted to film covering all
our angles of all our bases but with a
animism you can't do that every time the
virtual camera turns around it has to
create the the image so you have to be
much more disciplined about what you're
going to actually see in the final
program the whole process of making this
film starts with basically mapping out a
storyboard making sketches so that's
done with myself Nigel henbest is the
advisor consultant to make sure
everything's correct factually and
Jonathan Gibson who's the visual effects
designing a director and we go from the
script and John just starts making
sketches and drawing and I try react to
those drawings so we're creating kind of
a rising spiral of stuff which is kind
of going up in a you know sort of helix
yeah and we agree on the camera angles
and the kind of shots were gonna have
and he then maps it out for us on
storyboards little pencil drawings
Jonathan really is like the director of
photography on traditional shoot he's
he's like my cameraman he tells me
what's possible and what we can achieve
and shows me and draws the images and
says this is what we can do with the
camera we can turn it around here this
is how we're going to light it so it's
very much as though we're on location
talking together about how we're going
to cover a sequence except of course
it's a virtual sequence and not a real
sequence the danger with making a film
like this is because it's all animation
you could actually make up any images
you like but that's not what we're doing
with this this is trying to be as
rigorous and as accurate as possible so
with the help of Nigel we have created
as best we know the most accurate
picture all these images we're seeing of
course we're taking references from the
Hubble Space Telescope from from NASA
from all their fabulous imagery of Saint
Mars the next thing we do is actually
put those images onto our editing
machine and create a timed finished film
with arrows to point where the cameras
going to move it is quite liberating
because although you're constrained and
you know that you can only animate
certain things those things you can
animate unlike the real camera you can
go wherever you want with the virtual
camera you can go round through inside
out the sky's the limit I suppose for me
one of my favorite scenes as a trip to
Venus we make is in reality if anybody
dared to go there there'd be frazzled
burned
crushed squashed they wouldn't survive
so the fact that we can go there with a
virtual camera and take the audience on
what is a rollercoaster ride I think is
a great secret in fact as we track
across Venus there's that veneer
approaches a Soviet road that went down
onto the surface of Venus and sent back
great imagery which I gave me being able
to extrapolate the information from the
base our animation on this was certainly
a challenge to take on it's a landmark
film Lovisa temperatures and
this sort of important oh the chance to
actually take on something like that or
something I agree couldn't